The joe rogan experience.
They try everything.
This scare marijuana smokers.
Why?
Why is that?
They should just smoke weed and get
their dick sucked.
They would change the way they feel
about all this.
They'd be like,
I can't believe blowjobs feel so good,
dude.
Dude,
dude,
dude.
It's from someone who loves you.
Who tickles your balls when you come in
their mouth?
Hey,
while you're high Jesus Louisa's.
Okay.
They don't know about that.
Do they know about that?
Because if they do,
you know I would imagine if you're a,
the sheriff at Greenlee knows about
that.
If you're a girl and you smoke a couple
of hits a weed and then get your pussy
licked,
that's kind of feel so good.
Could you imagine like a shower feels
good when you're high?
You can imagine how good it feels for
girl.
Do you think your ass licked?
Do I like my ass?
Like,
yeah.
Listen,
you and I and you're never going to have
this conversation right now.
It ends here.
It ends here with you.
I'm not opening those doors.
What kind of a man asks another man.
This is like a fill out form for a
fucking gang bang video.
Okay.
Now do you like getting your ass like,
because if yes,
check the box to the right.
That should never come up.
You should go from you cradle to the
grave without anybody ever asking you do
you like it in your ass,
right?
Or maybe maybe that should be it.
That should be a fun thing about a
funeral is you have to write the answer
yes or no.
Like on a piece of paper and then have
it in your hand like when you're done.
Yeah,
like in the open casket,
I secretly love you.
Did you check his note?
That was a yes with two exclamation
points.
You see the problem with the question
like do you like your ass?
Licht is,
that's not how anybody ever asks it.
If they're gonna lick your ass,
right.
They don't go.
Do you like to get your ass loads?
They don't say that.
They would say,
do you want me to lick your ass?
Huh?
Huh.
They would have a lot of,
has in there.
Like,
all right.
Want me to look your ass?
Huh?
You do?
Like they're already affirming it cause
it's a risky thing to say like,
you want me to lick your ass?
Huh?
Let me try it again,
Joe.
This is an affirmation of it.
You know,
it's like you,
you want to,
we want that person to have an easy time
saying yes.
No,
no.
I,
it's like,
Huh?
You want me to look at your ass?
And you go,
well that would be cool.
Yo,
you fucking sick.
Fuck.
Fuck you.
I checked you asshole.
Right,
right.
The bedroom opens up,
the camera crew comes in,
you've been on the new show.
Do you want your ass comes like a big
court case where they tried to figure
out what what ha means when you add on
to it and then the lawyer tries to
defend it clearly if she used the word,
Huh?
She was,
she was trying to get a positive
affirmation out of him.
She was a manipulating his emotional
responses.
The natural responses of a person.
He was doing it to be polite.
You didn't really want his ass select
okay.
He didn't want her to feel bad.
She said hot already.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
as it was happening,
he was realizing he had made a mistake.
Yeah.
You know,
it'd be like joining an army that thinks
they're going to go out and fight big
foot.
Like you got all your fucking gear and
you're ready.
Go to the mountains,
like we are the sasquatch.
And He'd be like,
Oh,
what have I done?
What have I done?
I can't believe I'm going to go.
This is an army of people I've joined.
Fuck,
I made a mistake.
Shit.
He can't pull out of it.
That's what it's gotta be like.
It's crazy.
Well,
that's where you,
you know,
you are known for not just being,
uh,
one of the pioneers of MMA,
but you're known for that expression
Yamato Democracy that you have always,
you've always promoted that ideal,
this,
this Samurai spirit and this,
this spirit of Japan,
this way of,
of doing things wholeheartedly.
And you know,
you've talked openly that you freely
give yourself,
like when you would go to fight and you
would be ready to die.
Yes.
And not just saying that like you,
you would really reconciled it in your
mind.
You would say goodbye to your friends,
say goodbye to your family versus a fire
letters.
I wrote letters to people that I wanted
to say goodbye to every fight.
Yeah.
That's some deep shit.
You know,
it was the thing too is I'm
fighting to die flying to die.
You're going to train with the will to
die too,
so you can write it down as good
training I got in.
Yeah.
I mean I'm training every day before the
fight,
so I won't die in the fight.
I'm planning,
I'm okay.
I'm accepting the fact that I might die
there,
but I know that the better I can be is
the less chance to me dying in the rain.
So,
you know,
I'm not going to get up in the morning
and because I'm sore,
I'm not going to miss training because
I'm tired or I'm lazy because it'll
might be the difference in me living in
dying in the room.
So,
you know,
it helped me out a lot.
And then the training aspect and you
know,
the dieting,
I mean I want to eat,
I want to drink a coke,
but I'm trying to eat only good things
on my before my flight.
And it's,
it's a lot easier to do that when you're
in it to that level.
It can't hurt you,
you know,
to plan to die in the ring to,
to believe that and to train and to walk
that life for that three months while
training for the fight it,
they can't hurt you.
Is it difficult for you because you
earnestly embraced that thought process?
Is it difficult for you when you see
guys that are kind of dabbling in mma
that Kinda like half asking it,
not training hard enough?
Maybe they have some talent but they
don't really put their will and heart
into it.
Well,
it's a whole new era now.
Yeah.
Because back in the day we didn't get
paid good.
We weren't,
we weren't,
weren't that worried about,
you know,
losing a sponsor here,
right.
Being cut by the UFC,
you know,
that kind of stuff didn't,
because there was all these little
association with funding for so little
bit money.
The objective and the,
the,
the whole movement of that error was
different.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
when fighters start getting lazy,
Eh,
or they don't fight as hard or the tap
out a little sooner.
You know,
I understand that because there's a
whole new era because you're fighting
for a different reason though.
They're fighting for money.
They are fighting for living.
They're fighting for sponsors.
If we need to look good,
you know,
so it's easier when you're fighting for
those reasons.
Okay.
I mean,
there's only so much money will make you
do.
Hmm.
But if you're fighting for your honor
and you're fighting for your life,
it's a whole different level.
Yeah.
So
[inaudible].